it's been a long road for Hideo Kojima
but it seems like the Konami saga is
finally behind the super star game
developer now we swarmed an independent
studio appropriately titled Kojima
Productions that's pretty solid the
studio's official website has also
launched and the logo should feel pretty
familiar it was designed by Yoji
Shinkawa whose art is inseparable from
metal gear along with the logo comes a
mission statement from Kojima himself
it's a wonderful message to gamers and
creators everywhere saying we find one
another and compete with one another we
laugh together and cry together all
while playing together our experiences
bind us and liberate us to share our
most valuable experiences we create
stories and vent tools and evolve the
art of play play has been our ally since
the dawn of civilization you can read
the whole statement for yourself on the
website and while you're there why not
apply to work for Kojima himself the
studio is hiring artists programmers and
designers whatever it is the team is
designing you'll get to play it
exclusively on ps4 and PC and whenever
that project is revealed you can read
all about it on gamespot com